okay hey you guys ready yes yi oh hello
and welcome to this video
I'm here with Kingsley hola we just
recorded an episode of not too deep so
if you want to listen to that after this
video is over go to SoundCloud calm
slash not too deep with grace and listen
to the Kingsley episode
it didn't get deep but a lot of other
things were discussed yeah and so while
he was here I thought we'd play a game
because Kingsley is excellent at Twitter
and also excellent at celebrity culture
I thought we should play a game called
who tweeted yeah and what's gonna have
it is director producer Jack berry
off-camera has chosen a bunch of tweets
tweeted by the people that are lined up
on the cards in front of us he will read
us a tweet and then we have to guess who
tweeted it by just holding up a card and
the first person to hold up the correct
card gets a point the first person to
ten points is the winner okay that's not
simple enough makes sense yeah okay oh
the other part of this game is that
there could be multiple tweets by the
same person
all right jack let's play who's we did
okay tweet number one time to shut my
eyes for 10 hours and hope I dream about
cute boys and chillin with Beyonce and
unlimited free guacamole another stuff
by Tyler Oakley I didn't get it into the
buying is correct that is correct
ahh nipples are where titties go wrong
again
Jaden Jaden no one no ahh nipples I were
to go wrong oh god I hate the word yes
what was your logic I have no idea
wake up in the morning feeling like P
Diddy just kidding I woke up with a
wedgie feeling completely average no no
anything that sounds remotely like
hipster hitch I'm just running towards
him with the wedgie I mean none of these
people are average
oh goodness grace is feeling completely
average average you are correct listen I
know that's a good I know uh can you
please get off my penis can you please
get off my penis no I swear I just saw
this I wish I have photographic memory
yes that I didn't get I'm really shocked
okay what's the score three two one
act like oh I dropped my scarf in a
dirty public toilet should I keep it
xoxo
that's not a Miranda snake xoxo glozell
that is correct yeah yes she is the New
Age Gossip Girl hey oh my god I'm
getting [ __ ] better
my dick is in flames right I'm never
gonna get this one no no no no my dick
is in flames no no Taylor Swift god damn
it that can be a great rounds already on
a grande Ariana Grande you got it that's
right yeah yeah she's a wild card
say the words going on there eating
toast in the shower is the ultimate
multitask no there is any reason Mary
wouldn't eat oh she ate like a proble
good news in the show Taylor said no god
damn it she's her style yes my love just
clean my mouse pad hashtag ain't nobody
fresher than my click no no no yes I
know that lame sweet my parents are the
truest people I know cause of death
rocking out too hard to old school
Destiny's Child while driving in the
rain yes yeah
child isn't gonna be missing we are your
on grinder my username is dick on
grinder my user name is dick no yes okay
well it wasn't a woman
zach braff is the Tyler Oakley of
traditional media some might say saliva
always helps lighten the mood saliva
always helps lighten the mood yes yo at
Betty Crocker why would you discontinue
rainbow chip frosting what the heck am I
supposed to put on my funfetti cake how
can I turn 30 now ah yes yeah I have to
think of how old everyone was me Shaq
I'm at Knott's Berry Farm my butt's too
big to fit and deceits on ride ah that's
me yelling I think maybe she's got a
real earnest that megafest boat that's
too big to fit in the ride no no check
reading where Shaq treat every seven
years your body is completely replaced
with entirely new cells so just because
you look the same doesn't mean you are
Jaden Smith yeah an online dating
service that also brings you breakfast
bagels I know this someone tumblr this
up made you know Hannah Hart
that is a very specific uncle voice on
her Twitter bagel
really yeah Anna you've done a friend
too you've done this friend great this
friend terribly wrong
whew that was intense I wasn't it was a
good match though and also this games
really fun it's fun you really do think
that yeah it's hard especially you can't
see the tweet either just to hear how it
sounds out loud
well Kingsley thank you so much for
participating thank you and thank you
for being on the podcast don't forget to
go to SoundCloud calm slash not too deep
with grace to check out the full
interview with Kingsley and go over to
his YouTube channel and check it out and
tell them tell him that you came from
this video because I guess that's
informative when I lost yeah deep down
give him some words of encouragement so
that he continues on falsely guessing
who tweeted I don't know you gonna go
develop the bagel app I'd like to see
Adele fall I don't think that would be
very interesting to witness you know if
she bled out like a yodel
that's like bounces back up